think one thing I'm most excited about
with Twitter is he lost 750 million
dollars of a advertising per year
because 50 of the top 100 advertisers
dropped off that's a big number and to
replace that 750 million dollars all he
needs is 7.7 million people out of his
you know 250 million active followers to
pay eight bucks a month if 30 million
people pay eight bucks a month on
Twitter it's game over wholeheartedly
agree if there are some fitness apps
that can get a million users at 100
bucks a year there's no reason why a
media platform that owns all of the
attention yes I think it's completely
plausible they had 400 000 people had
the blue check mark when they started it
he is monetizing status or decreasing
the relative status but so many people
will buy that blue check mark because of
what it stood for before and some people
pay ten thousand twenty thousand a
hundred thousand dollars for these blue
check marks and so I think a lot of
people are going to want to do it